so weit so beiden mit seiner
rechtfertigung des vorzeitigen ausstiegs
aus afghanistan seine haltung ist ja
auch in der europäischen regierungen
scharf innerhalb und außerhalb der usa
kritisiert worden darauf werden wir im
laufe der sendung eingehen es hat ja nur
wenige tage gedauert um politische und
militärische investitionen von mehr als
einer billion
us-dollar in den wüstensand von
afghanistan zu setzen tausende
verlorener menschenleben zivilisten und
soldaten kommen noch dazu dieses
desaster ist das eine entscheidender für
die zukunft wohl etwas anderes die frage
ob sich die globale
sicherheitspolitische achse
unwiderruflich zu ungunsten des westens
verschiebt taliban an der macht hat der
westen versagt jetzt in der phoenix
runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde die
dinge haben sich beschleunigt die
afghanische armee hat keinen widerstand
geleistet aus welchen gründen auch immer
oder wenig widerstand da haben wir eine
falsche einschätzung gehabt und das ist
nicht der falsche deutsche einschätzung
sondern die ist weit verbreitet ja so
hören sich offenbarungseid an heute
abend abgegeben von der kanzlerin im
kanzleramt und damit herzlich willkommen
bei uns in der phoenix runde meine gäste
zugeschaltet ist jürgen trittin grünen
politiker und mitglied im auswärtigen
ausschuss des deutschen bundestages in
diesem ausschuss ebenfalls mitglied des
jürgen hardt von der cdu/csu-fraktion
sie sind gleichzeitig auch noch
außenpolitischer sprecher der
unionsfraktion im bundestag
hier im studio begrüße ich kristina dunz
stellvertretende leiterin im
hauptstadtbüro des redaktions netzwerkes
deutschland das ist ein zusammenschluss
mehrerer zeitungen und markus kaim ist
bei uns von der stiftung wissenschaft
und politik und das ist einer unserer
renommiertesten sogenannten think tanks
herr trittin 20 jahre aufbau von
rechtsstaatlichen demokratischen
strukturen zumindestens ist das ja
versucht worden in afghanistan und das
wird innerhalb von tagen zu staub war
dass die was war aus ihrer sicht die
größte fehleinschätzung des westens in
bezug auf afghanistan
größte fehleinschätzung war dass man
2012 als isaf beendet wurde nicht die
konsequenz gezogen hat mit einer
politischen vereinbarung dort abzuziehen
das hat übrigens sehr wichtig eben in
seiner ausführlichen stellungnahme
benannt er kriegt jetzt die prügel für
einen dilettantisch gemacht das abkommen
was donald trump ausschließlich mit den
taliban geschlossen hat aber wir müssen
uns selber fragen was uns geritten hat
über fast ein jahrzehnt
polizisten und soldaten eine armee
auszubilden von denen jedes jahr ein
drittel desertiert bis
genau so haben die sich jetzt verhalten
und deswegen sage ich die entscheidende
fehler wurde beginn dieses jahrzehnts
gemacht als man in dem wissen dass man
den konflikt militärisch nicht gewinnen
konnte die verabredung die man getroffen
hatte bei der veränderung von beendigung
von eis nicht vollzogen hat am ende ist
es schlimmer gekommen als man es damals
befürchtet weil das mandat mit dem man
da zunächst nach afghanistan
hineingegangen gesagt hat die
bundesregierung und die sie tragenden
parteien die stehen jetzt blamiert da
weil man ja die kanzlerin gesagt ja das
irgendwie nicht voraussehen konnte da
haben wir auch manche zweifel ob das
wirklich so richtig ist es wirkt so ein
bisschen als habe es nie eine
afghanistan strategie der
bundesregierung gegeben übernehmen sie
die verantwortung
ich glaube das haben wir auch in der
debatte um die verlängerung des
afghanistan mandats im frühjahr dieses
jahres deutlich gemacht und die
entscheidende punkt ist schon dass wir
die gemeinsame verabredungen dass wir
condition based also abhängig von der
entwicklung im lande unsere präsenz in
diesem land zurück fahren wir waren ja
mit bundeswehrsoldaten mit 6000 da jetzt
sind das 2000 gewesen am ende des
einsatzes dass wir davon abgerückt sind
weil donald trump ein datum verkündet
hat und damit sozusagen den taliban
dehnen ball auf den elfmeterpunkt gelegt
hat und noch fast genauso schlimm in der
afghanischen regierung hat nach meinem
eindruck die man geglaubt dass die
amerikaner tatsächlich nach der
präsidentschaftswahl ernst machen und
abziehen man hat da auch spekuliert dass
man auch da wenn man auf zeit spielt ein
weiteres verbleiben der truppen erreicht
und das ist eben nicht aufgegangen aus
sicht der afghanischen regierung ich
glaube wir hätten diesen abzug aus rsm
in der nächsten zeit wird keinen
zeitrahmen nennen aber vielleicht im
nächsten jahr oder übernimmt ja viel
besser gestalten können wenn wir nicht
diesen künstlichen zeitdruck erzeugt
hätten diese diese vor diese vor
steilvorlage für die taliban sondern
wenn wir sowohl auf der seite der
regierung als haushalte der taliban
etwas dafür bekommen hätten
zugeständnisse vereinbarungen
verlässliche grundlage auch bei der
afghanischen regierung eine stärkeres
engagement
dann hätten wir die bilder von heute
vielleicht verwalten können unterm
strich bleibt natürlich die
hauptverantwortung für die situation in
afghanistan das möchte ich auch ganz
klar sagen bei der afghanischen
regierung die in 20 jahren das nicht
geschafft hat trotzdem sie massive
wirtschaftliche rückendeckung hatte
massive militärische rückendeckung und
auch die rückendeckung des volkes in
demokratischen ihre eigenen partikulare
interessen zurückzustellen und dem
interesse des landes insgesamt zu
arbeiten und vor allem auch einen
ausgleich herbeizuführen im land
zwischen den unterschiedlichen
interessen punkten ob wir da vielleicht
hätten mehr moderieren oder mehr druck
ausüben können das werden wir
analysieren aber letztlich ist das in
aller erster linie natürlich schon dass
wir sagen auch gar nicht ist also
veranlassung tage passiert ist über die
verantwortung werde welche hat reden wir
ja gerade in der sendung und wir sind ja
noch beim sortieren der ursachen von uns
die westliche sicherheitspolitisch
scheint ja ein debakel zu sein wird denn
in zukunft die übrige welt auf die
sogenannte freie welt den westen pfeifen
gerade auch wenn man möglicherweise nach
unterstützung sucht die erschütterung
ist jetzt auf jeden fall da die
autorität des westens das vertrauen in
den westen ist massiv geschädigt und
wenn ich mir heute den
un-generalsekretär gut erich anhöre der
die aufständischen taliban
auffordert zu äußerster zurückhaltung
dann kann ich nur sagen was kümmert die
taliban was der mann in new york sagt
die werden da brutal vorgehen und die
die die welt sage ich mal die vielleicht
in anderen konflikten darauf wartet dass
der westen etwas regeln kann ist damit
völlig desillusioniert und ich möchte
herrn hart insofern widersprechen wenn
er die kritik hauptsächlich auf die
afghanische regierung lenkt und dann ja
auch auf die usa wieder ein ganz
wichtiger partner sind es sind natürlich
die internationalen truppen die
internationale gemeinschaft und damit
auch deutschland
in der welt und b im eigenen land weil
bundeswehreinsätze im ausland werden
damit jetzt viel viel kritischer und der
bundestag wird sich sehr genau überlegen
müssen ob er seine armee also die
parlamentsarmee noch einmal in einen so
großen jeweiligen konflikt check wobei
der in einem jahr noch stecken in mali
da man ja nicht genau abschätzen
herr kaim die wir wollen den blick noch
ein bisschen weiter wo könnte das
hinführen jetzt nicht nur was gerade in
afghanistan passiert haben wir heute
viele bilder gesehen in den finanzieren
sich stationen sondern was bedeutet das
eigentlich auch für die zukunft das
vakuum das die westliche sicherheits-
und außenpolitik hinterlässt das wird
immer größer da könnten ja zum beispiel
russland auf die idee kommen ob da noch
was in der ukraine geht oder china
könnte seine chancen ausloten
möglicherweise taiwan zu kopieren das
hat man ja schon angedroht sind solche
konflikte die sich gezielt gegen den
westen richten jetzt wahrscheinlicher
geworden durch afghanistan so will ich
nicht kenne wir können bei afghanistan
war anfangen da sehen wir das was sie
angesprochen haben ja schon im kleinen
dass der rückzug des westens der rückzug
der usa ein strategisches vakuum
hinterlassen haben und das vakuum in der
internationalen politik wird immer
gefüllt von anderen und sehen genau die
akteure die sogenannte an die fühlen
dass es ist russland ist china ist
gerade mal zwei oder drei wochen zurück
wo hochrangige taliban delegation in
moskau und in peking empfangen worden
sind und da konnte man die vorzeichen
jetzt schon lesen diesen
paradigmenwechsel dass sowohl moskau als
auch peking schon in rechnung stellten
vielleicht ich das was wir gestern
gesehen haben aber dass die taliban
zumindest eine dominante rolle spielen
würden und die ihnen klar gemacht haben
wir akzeptieren das was ihr vorhabt
solange wir unsere interessen
berücksichtigt und dass die chinesen
heute die
die macht der taliban zumindest nicht
verurteilt haben die russen gesagt an
die botschaft bleibt auch illustriert er
genau den punkt und man kann das
natürlich auf die globale ebene
hochziehen sagen wenn der westen sich
zurückzieht wohl die usa als
ordnungsmacht zurückziehen werden wieder
andere dieses vakuum füllen und auch das
sehen wir bereits in verschiedenen
regionalen kontexten auch in der
europäischen nachbarschaft wurf einmal
staaten wie die türkei anfangen die
europäische nachbarschaft zu bestimmen
china iran und andere mehr etwas was vor
20 jahren unvorstellbar gewesen ist und
damit würde ich sagen ist der meisten
freilich bedeutet unbedeutend geworden
habe an gestaltungskraft hatte deutlich
verloren ich würde gerne einen satz
aufnehmen dienst die gerade in der
ersten antwort von sich gegeben haben
was hat uns deutsche eigentlichen
geritten polizisten und soldaten
auszubilden die beiden ersten gegenwind
dann davon laufen jetzt wollen wir nicht
vergessen dass sie als
bundesminister 2001 als die
bundesregierung
afghanistan mitgeschossen mitbeschlossen
hat das war ja damals der satz des
bundeskanzlers gerhard schröder von der
uneingeschränkten solidarität mit den
usa nach dem elften september die grünen
waren mitglied in der bundesregierung
die oppositionsparteien die wichtigste
haben da auch mit gestimmt aber da war
dann and using freedom hieß ja dieser
einsatz der ihr damaliger kollege aus
dem verteidigungsressort dann etwas
später gesagt dass die bundesrepublik
auch am hindukusch verteidigt wird wenn
man das jetzt heute sieht aus heutiger
sicht war das auch eine art
grassierender blauäugigkeit in der
politischen klasse in deutschland auch
unter dem eindruck des 11 septembers
dass man da mitmachen musste mit den
amerikanern mitmachen musste aber sich
gar nicht so klar war ob das wirklich so
klug gewesen ist
sehen sie ich habe in einem aufsatz für
die blätter für deutsche und
internationale politik als bilanz des
afghanistan einsatzes vor einigen wochen
geschrieben ein jahr erfolgt 19 jahre
scheitern und das haben sie eben ganz
gut beschrieben es war ein erfolg das
taliban-regime und damit die
unterstützung von al-qaida gestürzt zu
haben das
an die nato das woran auch deutschland
mit gescheitert ist war der versuch am
ganges bern ohne und gegen die taliban
zu regieren das hat vielfältige ursachen
eine dieser ursachen ist gewesen dass
man zwar zusammen rein und am ende
zusammen rausgegangen ist aber nie
zusammen drin war die einen wollten dort
starten aufbauen staatliche strukturen
errichten das war die position der
europäer die anderen haben gesagt ich
zitiere donald trump via kelling
terrorists diese beiden prinzipien
konnte nicht zum erfolg und deswegen war
er richtige zeitpunkt die beendigung des
isaf mandats und seit diesem zeitpunkt
ist die mehrheit meiner fraktion der
auffassung gewesen diesen einsatz nicht
länger zu unterstützen und deswegen
haben wir immer gesagt es war falsch die
vereinbarungen die man damals getroffen
hat nicht umzusetzen ich will an der
stelle noch eine bemerkung machen zu dem
westen und seine rolle stimmt alles was
er ein vakuum lässt wird von anderen
gefüllt aber dieser westen wird aus
seinen eigenen werte nicht gerecht jeder
der die vereinbarung zwischen trump und
den taliban gelesen hat wusste das so
kommen wird und warum frage ich mich hat
niemand in der bundesregierung den
wünschen dem druck der eigenen
diplomaten folgen dafür sorge getragen
dass wenigstens diejenigen die sich im
vertrauen auf uns für demokratie
engagiert haben die für uns übersetzt
dort rechtzeitig ausgeflossen südens
seit juni hätte dieses geschehen müssen
es ist politisch nicht gewollt gewesen
und diese form der verantwortungslose
das ist der punkt wo ich sage hier
treten westliche demokratien ihre
eigenen werte mit füßen das geschehen er
hat das kann man ja noch ergänzen wenn
man der jetzt heute erfahren hat dass
der stellvertretende botschafter in
afghanistan
nach deutschland gekoppelt hat dass das
was jetzt gerade eintritt eigentlich
sich schon länger angekündigt hat und
man hat ihn im auswärtigen amt und
anderswo nicht ernst genommen hat was
heißt das eigentlich für die
professionalität wir reden jetzt von der
deutschen politik von der
bundesregierung die die außenpolitik ja
verantwortet was heißt das eigentlich
wenn so etwas möglich ist und heute alle
so tun als seien sie völlig überrascht
gestern nachmittag das jetzt kabul doch
in die hände der taliban gefallen ist
also auch ich bin
nicht erst seit diesem diesem ereignis
der letzten tage sondern auch als bei
den putsch in mali hatten zudem
offensichtlich auch keine und zwar
geheimdienstquellen weder die deutsche
noch ausländische geheimdienste etwas
mitbekommen haben dass dort wo christen
gegen die legitime regierung des staates
mali putzt und wir sind sozusagen in
diesem land gerade präsent mit den un
und mit der europäischen union die frage
müssen wir schon stellen warum ob unser
sensor unser instrumentarium solche
dinge zu erkennen und darauf zu
reagieren ob das ausreichend gerüstet
ist uns glaube allerdings dass nicht nur
wir sondern viele anderen inklusive
amerikanische geheimdienste ja man sagt
sogar die iran
war überrascht von der entwicklung in
dem land wie schnell das vor anliegen
das ist ja nun mal ein nachbar der mit
enormer sensorik nach afghanistan hinein
ausgerüstet ist das eben doch diese
kampflose übergabe aller städte
inklusive der hauptstadt diese enorme
beschleunigung des prozesses verursacht
hat und das haben alle unterschätzt das
haben die deutschen unterschätzt das
haben auch die amerikaner unterschätzt
sonst würden sie ja jetzt nicht massiv
truppen an den flughafen schicken ich
möchte aber an einem punkt trennt ihn
wieder sprechen also die frage wie wir
unsere leute und wie wir die ortskräfte
die für uns gearbeitet haben mit ihren
familien aus dem land herausholen
beschäftigt uns ja nicht erst seit juni
sondern
schon im frühjahr wir haben im ausschuss
nur einfach drüber geredet sz rund 2000
ortskräfte plus inklusive
familienangehörige nach deutschland
gekommen weitere sind im land das hat
natürlich
einige gegeben die ausreisen wollten und
die die möglichkeit nicht bekommen haben
das müssen wir analysieren aber eine
untätigkeit eine generelle untätigkeit
aus politischem willen das kann ich
nicht erkennen dass fans bin ich auch
ein viel zu weit gehen dem vorwurf und
wir werden natürlich im auswärtigen
ausschuss und den anderen gremien die
frage erörtern ob jemand etwas falsch
gemacht hat ich glaube dass wir jetzt
erstmal die daumen drücken müssen das
uns beiden flugzeuge die auf geräten
gleich doch heute nacht in kabul landen
können und leute rausholen können
richtung oder das ist dem aus
ich glaube wir beide wünschen uns dass
diese beiden zeugen landen können und
das war möglichst viele leute raus und
gut mir aber ihr eigener
fraktionskollege ulrich diese werde
heute morgen erklärt es war ein riesiger
fehler den antrag der grünen jetzt
unbürokratisch die leute auch ohne visum
im zweifel auch ohne pass auszuholen
dass wir den abgelehnt kann wir haben
vor drei tagen noch wünsche gehabt von
botschaftsmitarbeitern menschen die für
die deutsche botschaft in kabul
übersetzt haben die von herrn seehofer
kein visum bekommen haben und deswegen
dort jetzt fest sitzen das ist politik
gewesen und der hintergrund ist ganz
einfach noch vor zwei wochen wollten
herr scholz nahm maß und herr seehofer
in dieses land menschen erschienen und
ich finde sie sollten die größe haben
ihres kollegen kiesewetter der gesagt
hat leute das war falsch wir hätten das
anders machen müssen will er gar nicht
lange drauf und weisen aber ich finde
schon wenn man über den westen und seine
werte redet dann muss man an einem
solchen abend auch das
also am mittwoch gibt es ja eine
sondersitzung des auswärtigen
ausschusses wo diese themen ja
sicherlich auch noch mal angesprochen
werden ich würde gerne noch auf
etwas anderes kommen und zwar die frage
jetzt wir suchen ja auch was ist da zu
diesem desaster geführt wir haben ja
schon einige begriffe gehört und auch
die frage ob da wirklich westliche werte
richtig eingehalten worden sind ob die
definition auch klar was wir da
eigentlich verloren haben lag das auch
so ein bisschen an gedrechselten
begriffen sowie uneingeschränkte
solidarität
oder was ja auch im zusammenhang mit
afghanistan öfters ins feld geführt
wurde das seit bewaffnete
entwicklungshilfe
das ging so ein bisschen wie brunnen
bohren mit knarre auf den rücken findet
diese halbherzigen verbrechen etwas
verschämten formulierungen das kind
nicht beim namen zu nennen das auch dazu
geführt hat dass hier völlig unklar war
warum wir eigentlich in afghanistan sind
zu beginn hatte ja der damalige
verteidigungsminister sie um das
angesprochen gesagt dass deutschlands
sicherheit auch am hindukusch verteidigt
werde das stimmte was den bündnisfall
die solidarität mit den usa betraf und
auch die gefahr durch taliban und al
kaida in afghanistan aber es war schon
damals mein gefühl und ich war mehrfach
mit herrn struck in afghanistan danach
gewesen dass man der deutschen
bevölkerung natürlich eine
eine erklärung an die hand geben musste
warum das eine gute sache ist also warum
das auch für uns wichtig ist es ist dann
aber sehr klar und sehr hart ende so
ungefähr
2009/2010 als kriegseinsatz beschrieben
worden und spätestens da war ja allen
klar und als die ersten
toten deutschen soldaten zurück kam und
die schwer verwundeten also es kann
keine illusion geben was das für ein
einsatz war und es konnte auch keine
illusion geben das eine dass eine
ankündigung wann genau die
internationalen truppen draußen sind
dazu führen werden dass die taliban das
als signal verstehen und was ich nicht
nachvollziehen kann bei meinen besuchen
da ist uns gezeigt wurden wie die wie
die deutschen die afghanische polizei
ausbilden und
was man ihn an die hand gibt uns schon
da haben deutsche soldaten immer gesagt
die desertieren die laufen über manchmal
schicken die taliban defekt leute für
die ausbildung denn die ist ja gut sie
waren also schon während des einsatzes
und zwar vor jahren verunsichert ob das
wirklich aufgeht was sie da machen und
dass die das im frühjahr oder mit diesem
beschluss sie gehen raus war konnte man
überhaupt nicht mehr sicher sein dass
die afghanische armee da so steht wie
man sie meinte ausgebildet zu haben und
deswegen glaube ich nicht wirklich dass
alle so überrascht sind und wenn ich
herrn beiden zu hören dann hört sich das
für mich einfach an wie lieber ein ende
mit schrecken auf kosten der afghaninnen
und afghanen aber ich hole meine leute
raus denn alles was jetzt gemacht wird
wird keine hilfe mehr für die menschen
dort seien die ihre ganze hoffnung auf
den westen gesetzt haben frauen und
mädchen werden wieder unterdrückt werden
vergewaltigt werden verschleppt werden
es gab viele menschen die hoffnung in
den westen hatten der ist brutal
enttäuscht war diese hoffnung ist brutal
enttäuscht worden und ich habe das
gefühl dass es einkalkuliert worden da
kam ich würde gerne noch auf einem
weiteren begriff herumreiten der ist
auch gerade schon gefallen
dass man wenn sich journalistinnen und
journalisten bei politikerinnen und
politikern beliebt machen wollten das
kommt ja gelegentlich vor dann haben sie
der im ersten jahrzehnt des afghanistan
einsatzes von krieg und kriegseinsatz
gesprochen und dieses wort hat die
politik wie der teufel das weihwasser
gescheut dazu hat man sich erst später
bekannt ist auch dass so ein beispiel
dafür dass wir uns nie so richtig klar
waren was machen wir dort was wollen wir
dort und dass am ende das sozusagen ganz
zwangläufig jetzt in diese richtung
gegangen ist in dieses gegangen ist
nämlich dass wir wie die begossenen
pudel da abziehen müssen also wer sich
dafür interessiert er konnte den
mandatstext schon lesen was die
bundeswehr dort machen soll also das ist
ja keiner kann wissen lesen
erst biss also noch mit 15
selbstständig für sicherheit sorgen und
die afghanischen sicherheitskräfte dabei
unterstützen mit dem exekutiv mandat von
isaf und dann mit rsm resolution port
menschen nur noch nachgeordnet also
ausbildung ausbildung aber ich würde ihn
zu stimmen dass die deutsche politik da
auch für noch unschärfe verantwortlich
ist weil wenn wir uns heute mal revue
passieren lassen woran der
afghanistan-einsatz gemessen wird dann
fahren ja häufig die mädchenschulen die
frauenrechte freie faire wahlen
medien und anderes mehr was nie im
mandatstext gestanden hat also dafür ist
die bundeswehr wie in afghanistan
gewesen wenn wir aber mal in mandats
debatten nicht texte marge debatten der
letzten jahre schauen dann ja haben
politiker häufig genau diese
begrifflichkeit verwendet und in einem
dazu legitimiert also was passiert ist
man einen militäreinsatz gehabt der aber
mehr mehr zivile mit zivilen zielen
legitimiert worden ist und dadurch ist
diese unscharfe entstanden die sie
angesprochen haben dass man sagt sind
wir eigentlich zivil dort unterwegs sind
frauenrechte und mädchenschulen das
anliegen der bundesheer oder es ist doch
die ausbildung von afghanischen
sicherheitskräften so sind da auch die
bewertung bewertungsmaßstäbe angekommen
oder jeder benutzt unterkriegen -
maßstäbe um zu sagen sind wir da
eigentlich erfolgreich sind wir nicht
erfolge ein die in der natur der sache
wenn man auch
mädchenschule und cook in afghanistan
kann man argumentieren vergleichsweise
erfolgreich und hitze wurde feststellen
den zustand der sicherheitskräfte warfen
sich an dieser
gilt das auch für die usa was ich gerade
oder sogar gleiche hat gilt das auch für
die für das hat ihm auch für die usa wo
sie gesagt haben diese
unentschlossenheit dieser vermischung
von zivilen und militärischen aufgaben
wir legen jetzt schon beiden gerade
gehört haben ich würde so etwas weniger
und vor einige und für beide gilt jetzt
ganz eindeutig das was hier angesprochen
haben ist nur zuzustimmen sind in
politische rahmenbedingungen die wir
verantwortlich sind dass die usa diesen
einsatz beenden vorbei macht ernst mit
seinem paradigma us- von profifoto
mittelkreis also anders formuliert es
muss für die amerikanischen bürger für
die amerikanische bürger etwas dabei
heraus kommen aus der amerikanischen
außenpolitik und was wir in europa so
ein bisschen schamhaft übersehen ist das
jetzt zumindest bis ende letzter woche
weil den letzten meinungsumfragen große
zustimmungswerte genießt weil der
entscheidung an sich aus afghanistan
zurück ich will nicht leugnen dass sich
das mittlerweile verschoben haben mag
aber ende letzter woche war das noch
deutlich erkennbar
vermutlich wollten sie darauf genau
antworten darf ich vielleicht hat die
frage die möglicherweise auch gut dazu
passt gleich hinterher schinken ist es
denn diese entschluss losigkeit
die wir so an den tag gelegt haben uns
nicht zu entscheiden können was das
eigentlich für ein mandat ist ist das
wesentliche ursache für das scheitern in
afghanistan
also ich möchte das nicht so kritisch
sehen wie das crm angesprochen hat weil
ja unser ziel schon war dass wir durch
einen zivilen aufbau des landes ein
stückweit
gesellschaftspolitische resilienz gegen
die taliban erreichen also unsere
erwartung war ja dass dadurch dass wir
familien zeigen wie gut dass das das
mädchen zur schule gehen und dass das
eben auch über jahre und jahrzehnte
passiert wenn sie sehen dass die
infrastruktur funktioniert wenn sie
sehen dass entsprechend die
lebenserwartung steigt die
gesundheitsversorgung sich verbessert
und sofort dass sie ein stück weit
stärker eine eine an der
widerstandskraft entwickeln gegen das
was was eben 25 jahre vorher passiert
war mit der der gewaltsamen
machtübernahme der taliban da ob sich
das jetzt auch mal von vornherein
nachdem was für den letzten tag gesehen
haben sagen muss das hat auch nicht
funktioniert oder ob wir davon etwas in
den nächsten monaten und jahren der
nebenwerte im land das das werden wir
zum heutigen zeitpunkt noch nicht sagen
können aber wir haben den bundestag wird
es um die auslandseinsätze der
bundeswehr gegen natürlich um die
militärische komponente gesprochen
wenngleich wir immer wussten dass wir
ein großer teil der finanziellen mittel
der bundesrepublik deutschland in den
zivilen aufbau des landes in die zivilen
strukturen stecken und nicht in die in
die militärischen kooperation und das
war eigentlich auch immer unser
gemeinsamer ansatz vielleicht ist es
nicht gelungen das hinreichend deutlich
zu machen ich persönlich habe nie das
gefühl gehabt dass wir so getan als sei
das ba sie so ein bisschen unterstützung
von entwicklungshilfe was die soldaten
da machen ich bin am tag das des
zwischenfalls an der tat spricht südlich
von kundus vier gefallene deutsche
soldaten in afghanistan gewesen weil ich
ihm zufällig da war auch mit
kameradinnen und kameraden von diesen
soldaten gesprochen ich hatte nie eine
version dass das ein sehr gefährlicher
grausame einsatzes ich habe auch einen
landtagskollegen in meinem wahlkreis der
selbst jäger offizieren in afghanistan
bau und schlimme dinge erlebt hat also
wer das wissen wollte und wir haben es
auch immer so thematisiert wir haben das
nie klein geredet aber wir haben
natürlich gesagt die zivile komponente
eigentlich geht es um den zivilen aufbau
des landes und die entwicklung einer
resilienz gegen feindliche übernahme
durch taliban oder gar terrors gut ich
würde gerne wenn sie gestatten das
geopolitische ein bisschen weiter den
blick was diesen konflikt angeht und
besser gesagt dass aus diesem konflikt
jetzt folgen könnte herr trittin nach
den erfahrungen
die die menschen in syrien vor einigen
jahren oder jetzt in afghanistan gemacht
haben mit den mit dem westen und der
westlichen politik die ja diese menschen
die menschenrechte schützen sollte ja
besonders oder eigentlich fast
ausschließlich für humanität steht in
diesem weltpolitischen spiel ist da
jetzt der nahe und mittlere osten also
sozusagen von syrien bis afghanistan für
den westen in zukunft eine no-go-area
dass man eigentlich darauf verzichtet
den westen da weiterhin als schutzmacht
oder als interessens macht zu
akzeptieren
naja gegen sie so fragen in diesen
ländern ist der westen nicht immer nur
als schutzmacht angesehen worden waren
sie mal ein iraner mit den erfahrungen
von 53 dem sturz der dortigen regierung
ob man das als schutz empfunden hat oder
als anmaßenden kolonialismus
ich glaube dass man diese geschichte
gerade mit blick auf die intervention
die europäische staaten die die usa in
diesen ländern gemacht haben sehr genau
anschauen muss selbstverständlich hat
die problematik warten syrien zu tun mit
der fahrlässigen und überzogenen
intervention in libyen die übrigens in
deutschland alle parteien einschließlich
der union nicht mitgemacht haben ich
glaube wir hatten gute gründe dafür und
die weitere entwicklung hat uns leider
belehrt dass das auch nichts nutzt wir
müssen uns weiter mit dem problem
herumschlagen aber ich finde eines er
hat von uns recht wir werden künftig
gegenüber menschen die sagen wieso
schickt ihr irgendwo soldaten hin
ehrlicher argumentiert müssen es war ihm
nicht ehrlich zu sagen wir sind dort
damit mädchen zur schule gehen können
wir sind dort zehn jahre nicht gewesen
obwohl mädchen nicht zur schule gehen
können wir sind erst 2003 nach
afghanistan gegangen weil wir von dort
eine massive bedrohung bekommen haben
und dann haben wir gesagt wir wollen
dieses land von dieser bedrohung
befreiend für uns wäre ein
sicherheitspolitisches interesse und
dann wollen wir das dieses land nicht
mehr von den kräften die das gemacht
haben regiert werden das war das
militärische ziel und dafür war auch der
aufbau ziviler strukturen ein mittel zum
zweck aber ich finde wenn man künftige
intervention rechtfertigen will muss man
sich ein stück ehrlicher machen als die
öffentlichen begründung er kein hat auf
die unterschiede zwischen den
mandatstext und den mandats debatten im
bundestag hingewiesen da wird nötig sein
wenn man überhaupt wieder an so etwas
denkt sollte ich glaube dass ein kleiner
zu
sanitär begründet intervention ein sehr
schwere fahrers
der vaart ja ganz kurz nur als er tritt
ihn
das ist richtig wir sind nicht
hingegangen damit kinder in den frauen
mädchen in die schule gehen können
sondern damit wir den internationalen
tourismus da austrocknen aber richtig
ist auch so lange wir da waren konnten
mädchen zur schule gehen zehn mal zu
viel junge kinder sind entscheide
gegangen wie vorher und ob das in der
zukunft wenn wir jetzt nicht mehr da
sind weiter möglich ist steht er in
frage also gar nicht das schon auch
einen zusammenhang zwischen und das
wahrscheinlich ein ganzheitliches jahre
zeichnen sollten diesen dank genossen
hat und ich glaube die 20 jahre werden
am ende ich hoffe dass es nicht so weit
kommt dass die menschen da sehnsüchtig
darauf zurückblicken müssen weil sie ein
schlechtes leben bald aber sie werden
glaube ich eher als positive jahre
bewertet werden in der rückschau der
menschen die heute in afghanistan eben
weil neben freiheitsgrade da waren die
jetzt möglicherweise verloren geben und
mit unseren 1000 mann und dem geld was
wir investiert haben haben wir das ein
stück weit mit gewährleistet und
deswegen war das kein einsatz der von
vornherein völlig in die hose gegangen
ist frage
wie weit man mit nostalgie in
afghanistan weiter kommt ich würde gerne
noch auf einen aspekt eingehen jugendamt
habe gesagt wir müssen uns ehrlich
machen in zukunft mit solchen
auslandseinsätzen
wenn man sich mal die landkarte an sind
angefangen nordafrika über die arabische
halbinsel dann den nahen und mittleren
osten eben bis zum hindukusch das ist
eine ansammlung von pulverfässer
brauchen jetzt gar nicht alle aufzählen
das ist ja auch bekannt um welche länder
es sich da handelt kann es sein dass uns
da gleich die nächste niederlage droht
ich geht man ein paar beispiele im iran
dass das atom abkommen scheitern dass
der irak doch noch auseinander fällt
dass es in libyen zu schweren
auseinandersetzungen kommt ganz zu
schweigen vom zustand in der sahelzone
wo eine brutale terror organisation boko
haram ihr unwesen treibt wo würth den
besten seiner nächste niederlage
möglicherweise erleiden meine these wäre
würde immer weniger in die wir lagen
erleiden weil er immer weniger interview
wird weil das ist doch eine der
schlussfolgerungen die wir aus
afghanistan ziehen werden ihr glaubt
doch nicht allen ernstes dass die nato
dass die europäische union das die für
eine nation so eine vergleichbare
mission auch nur mit spitzen fingern
anpacken wird das ist doch eine der
vielleicht naheliegenden auch
verständlich nähren die aber gewaltige
geopolitisch mali könnte aber so eine so
1 1 hätten ja und ich bin sicher mal
lieber nix mandatsverlängerungen
angesichts der erfahrung von afghanistan
ganz anders gegen das licht gehalten
werden und ganz anders geprüft werden
und man wird viel akkurater fragen
erinnert uns doch vieles anders was er
in afghanistan gesehen haben man mag
gerne kurzfristigen perspektive sagen
das ist toll dass die nato keine
intervention gemacht dass die eu das
nicht mehr anpacken würde das die
verändert nicht mal anpacken werden aber
sie habe die pulverfässer wie sie es
genannt haben angesprochen wir sind ja
nicht von einem friedlichen zonen geben
die populäre peripherie ist voller
krisen und was es bräuchte wäre ein
effektives
internationales krisenmanagement unter
obhut deflation und dass wir immer
weniger sehen also die
handlungsfähigkeit der internationalen
organisation wird nach afghanistan eher
kleiner werden weil der handlungswillen
kleiner wird und unter aspekten
internationalen sicherheit sollte uns
das eigentlich ihre zu denken geben für
diese internationale sicherheit haben
wir in der nato uns ja auch ausgestellt
und da haben wir ja einen verbündeten
vielleicht auch gehabt der uns gerade
bei der zu den beziehungen zum nahen und
mittleren osten eigentlich so als brücke
auch als geographische brücke dient
nämlich die türkei aber ganz
offensichtlich nimmt sie diese rolle
nicht mehr ein und stellt sich
eigentlich eher gegen die interessen der
nato erschwert das jetzt ganz besonders
für die nato staaten in diesen staaten
ja nicht zu intervenieren aber dafür
seinen friedensbemühungen und die
entschärfung von konflikten zu
unterstützen dass wir die türkei da
nicht mehr auf unserer seite haben ja
das ist ganz klar mit ja zu beantworten
was ich zu dieser debatte sagen noch
noch dazu sagen möchte was für die
planung solcher einsätze entscheidend
ist und was zu wenig gewesen ist und was
mehr gemacht werden muss ist wenn man
sagt man geht rein dass man nicht nur
sagt man geht gemeinsam wieder raus
sondern dass man sagt wie dass es eine
exit strategie gibt in dem moment wo man
einen solchen einsatz beginnt und da
sind wir bei jedem land die dass es
treffen würde mit einem konflikt dass
man sich vorher klar macht
wenn man neben luftschlägen bodentruppen
schickt wie werden die da wieder
rauskommen ohne das land im stich zu
lassen also hoffnung zu wecken und nicht
nur sehnsüchtig in die vergangenheit
dann zu sehen das ist das mal gab
freiheitsrechte und mädchenschulen zum
beispiel sondern wie man das dann
erhalten kann und das habe ich beim
afghanistan-einsatz
immer gedacht wie wird man professionell
da wieder raus gehen können und wann und
das ist mir oder mali einsatz auch nicht
klar und das ist natürlich eine
ein manko auch der nato und der
absprachen die exit-strategie an wann
bin ich ein mandat ist ja jetzt nicht
zum ersten mal dass wir dieses problem
haben im irak krieg war das ein großes
problem es war auch im vietnamkrieg ein
großes problem es gibt ja schon
historische beispiele die abschreckend
wirken gerade auf die westliche
staatengemeinschaft und trotzte macht
man ja offensichtlich immer wieder den
gleichen fehler
ich kann nachvollziehen dieses oder oder
was ich damals auch richtig fand dass
das eine reaktion geben musste auf die
anschläge vom 11 september und dass man
sich auch wehren musste und das erstmals
den bündnisfall ausgerufen wurde das war
ja alles eine auch eine gewisse hektik
und eine schnelle reaktion und von da ab
hätte man schon mit planen müssen wie
man wieder rauskommt und ob man nun
der präsident der usa hat ja gesagt er
will ich noch fünf jahre diesen einen
satz laufen lassen aber wenn man aus dem
bol trächtigen gründen dass man vor dem
zwanzigsten jahrestag dieses anschlags
da wieder rauskommen möchte dass man das
noch mal zurück gestellt hätte und sich
noch mal überlegt hätte zusammen wie man
geordnet abziehen kann oder wie man
etwas über tragen kann dann wäre das
ganz ganz wichtig gewesen und eine sache
zu den mädchenschulen es haben übrigens
auch ganz viele bundeswehr soldaten die
einen militärischen auftrag hatten als
begründung warum sie da sind am ende
gesagt wir haben aber dafür gesorgt dass
mädchen wieder zur schule gehen und auch
die soldaten die schwerst verwundet
wurden die beine verloren haben die bei
anschlägen schwerst verletzt wurden
haben gesagt es war für eine gute sache
wenn das jetzt wegfällt weil das mal
gewesen ist dann hat dieser ganze
einsatz wirklich nur die bilanz
bitterkeit und dass es das er umsonst
war ich würde gerne noch auf einen
aspekt jürgen trittin eingehen dem
zusammenhang mit afghanistan jetzt auch
in den vordergrund rückt wir haben schon
kurz angesprochen die rolle chinas
afghanistan hat ja eine 65 kilometer
lange grenze mit china ist ja
möglicherweise auch in dieser strategie
der neuen seitenstraße den handelswegen
nach westen wichtig afghanistan es was
viele nicht wissen auch ein sehr
rohstoffreiches land das muss man
eigentlich nur befrieden und dann die
rohstoffe ausbeuten gleichzeitig wollen
die chinesen jahr auch das habe ich am
anfang ja schon gesagt möglicherweise
ein bisschen ihrem hinterhof aufräumen
also die wirklich unbestrittene vormacht
in ostasien werten ist das sind die
chinesen daher genau auf dem richtigen
weg und inwieweit gefährte das dann auch
westliche interessen
bei aller doppelmoral china ssten die ja
auf der einen seite die muslimische
minderheit im benachbarten xinjiang
massiv unterdrücken mit massiver
unterdrückung gegen diese menschen
vorgehen die eine panische angst haben
vor islamistischen terror der sie
durchaus ja auch heimgesucht hat auf dem
tiananmen-platz china ist der gewinner
dieser entwicklung
china ist enger bündnispartner
pakistans nämlich jenes pakistans was
wiederum die schutzmacht für die taliban
ist und die verlierer in dieser region
an dieser auseinandersetzung ist indien
indien der größte geber von zivile
entwicklungshilfe in pakistan ist durch
diese macht übertragen an den rand
gedrängt worden
dennoch ich glaube dass china in erster
linie daran interessiert ist seine aus
ihrer sicht pekings sicht unruhige
südwestecke ruhig zu halten ob es china
gelingt was wieder russland noch den usa
noch europa gelungen ist nämlich zugriff
zu finden auf die reichhaltigen
bodenschätze afghanistans das ist eine
offene frage aber sie werden das mit
sicherheit mitnehmen wenn sich dafür die
gelegenheit will china ist der gewinner
dieser entwicklung in der region vor er
hat also wenn china jetzt gestärkt wird
auch durch diese vorgänge nach
afghanistan obwohl das land kaum jahr
etwas militärisch dafür getan hat was
bedeutet das jetzt für die strategie
gegenüber china es gibt ja da in
südostasien eine menge imperialer
bestrebungen des reichs der mitte der
westen schickte er jetzt einen größeren
militärkonvoi in den sogenannten
indopazifik also die dortige
maritime gegen da ist die bundeswehr mit
einer fregatte beteiligt namens bayern
angesichts der vorgänge in afghanistan
hat das nicht etwas operettenhafte
ich glaube dass jürgen trittin recht hat
mit seiner feststellung dass wir als
eine der zentralen lehren aus dem
afghanistan einsatz die schlussfolgerung
ziehen müssen dass es zu wenig
gemeinsame formulierung von gemeinsamen
zielen interessen auf seiten der allianz
gegeben hat bis hin zu dem punkt dass
dann die trompeten dann einseitig die
sind abzugstermin festgelegt hat wovon
wichtige bündnispartner aus der zeitung
erfahren haben wenn wir uns besser
abstimmen würden wären wir mit diesen
einsätzen und mit den strategien auch
erfolgreicher und das zweite ist dass
wir meines erachtens bei dem thema
afghanistan zu wenig in augenschein
genommen haben diese geopolitische
dimension die diese afghanistan konflikt
hat ich habe bis zum heutigen tag nicht
verstanden warum pakistan zwar
einerseits von amerika
spieler hinsicht unterstützt wird zum
anderen aber nicht zu gewinnen war für
eine verein stock der massiven
unterstützung der taliban
die taliban wären niemals so stark wie
sie jetzt sind wenn nicht pakistan die
ganze zeit dieser frage auf der anderen
seite gespielt hätte das sind fragen die
wir auch offen mit unseren
bündnispartnern besprechen müssen und
wohl für zukünftige einsätze ich denke
jetzt einmal die wo ja auch
unterschiedliche interessen
unterschiedlicher akteure wechseln ich
frage beim aldi immer kommen wir denn
noch klar mit den verschiebt
verschiedenen konzentrischen kreisen den
staaten gemeinsam versuchen die
situation zu stabilisieren
wir brauchen mehr koordination
abstimmung und am ende brauchen wir auch
eine starke europäische stimme aber auch
hier bedarf es einer engeren abstimmung
innerhalb europas denn auch da haben wir
ja nicht unbedingt in allen fragen
konsens auch nicht in afghanistan wird
auch nicht einmal ich jetzt haben sie
die frage nach china clever umschifft da
kann man stellen
wie was bedeutet das eigentlich was
welchen einfluss kann da überhaupt der
westen noch haben wenn er jetzt in einem
solchen land wie afghanistan schon
versagt vielleicht mit einer kurzen
antwort also ich glaube die inselflieger
hat ist ausdruck der solidarität mit den
usa und iris group konflikt ist mit dem
münchner ich glaube operativ hat das
keine bedeutung und deutschland und
europa würde sich völlig überleben
militärische präsenz zu zeigen mit
ernsthaften militärische ambitionen gut
das ist ja auch im schlepptau der usa
die sich dort die dort flagge zeigen
letztes stichwort uns jeden zusammenhang
mögliche neue flüchtlingswelle was ist
da zu erwarten und wie sollte reagiert
werden da hat die bundeskanzlerin heute
in ihrer pressekonferenz schon mal eine
grenze gezogen wie hat gesagt man darf
die fehler von 2015 nicht wiederholen
indem man
das welternährungsprogramm nicht
finanziell gut genug ausstattet und den
un hcr nicht ausreichend unterstützt für
mich war das eine klare ansage an vor
der bundestagswahl an kritische deutsche
bürgerinnen und bürger dass die ängste
nehmen möchte dass es wieder zu einer
flüchtlingswelle wie es damals hieß kam
und ansonsten kann man nur sagen sie es
da doch sehr hart geworden und sie hat
ihre flüchtlingspolitik doch verändert
und schiebt dabei allem drama was in
afghanistan sich abspielt ein riegel vor
indem sie sagt wir helfen den
flüchtlingen in den nachbarstaaten aber
gelassen sie nicht erst mal nach dort
bis nach europa unter schuld unia in der
sendung war das erst in ihrer letzten in
den letzten statement darauf hingewiesen
wurde dass das im wahlkampf uns befinden
und dass er möglicherweise auch ein
wahlkampfthema ist außenpolitisch wie
auch was die migrations und
flüchtlingspolitik angeht ich bin an
gemisch bei jürgen trittin bei jürgen
hardt bei kristina dunz und bei markus
kaim liebe zuschauer jetzt folgt phoenix
der tag mit michael krons und weiteren
umfassenden berichten und aktuellen
informationen über das drama die
tragödie in afghanistan